[音楽]
ムートン
僕は何のために生きてるんだろうか
夜目を通して眠る前
こんな問いが頭に浮かんできます
皆さんはどうでしょうか
最近自分について深く考えながら眠りについたのはいつですか
きっと多くの人はスマホの画面に映る他人のことを考えながら眠りにつく
そんな夜の方が多いのではないでしょうか
僕は何のために生きてるんだろうか
そんなことを考えてもどうにもならないって言っ
結局一テレビなんでわからないんだから
確かにこのと言えば皆が ae に向き合い続けていく
答えのない問いなんだと思います
でも多くは京子のスピーチを聞いた後皆さんにやってほしいことがあります
それは1日に5分だけ
自分と向き合う時間を作ってみてほしいということです
そうすればこんな難解な問いにも向き合える
そんな気持ちになれるはずです
物語
これが今日
このスピーチで一番伝えたい多くのアイディアです
僕はこの物語というアイデアが
皆さんの人生そして生きている世界を拾っていくと考えています
超僕の話を聞いて物語というアイディアに共感してもらえたのなら
今日からあなただけの物語と一緒に生きて見てほしいと思っています
5今日は何のために生きてるんだろうか
この問いを過去現在未来と栗分けて考えてみるぞ
この話題というアイディアを軸としたこんなプロセスに分解することができます
まずはこれまでの人生という過去の物語を振り返ることですっ
自分を見つめ直すこと思う
次に
今日1日の物語を振り返ったときに幸せだったと思える日々を過ごすけど
そしてこれからさっきの未来の物語を思い浮
やりたいことに挑戦していること
この3つのステップを含めた一連のプロセスについ
一つ目から順番に説明していきたいと思っています
まず最初のステップである
自分を見つめ直すことに関する僕の経験を
お話します
僕は高校生の頃に熱波
こっ西鶴中南米の国に留学していました今
僕の通っていた学校が世界約70カ国から生徒が集まった君ので
非常に多様性に富んだ環境でした
そんなある日生徒それぞれの宗教について話すという授業がありました
みんなが順番に宗教観について語っていけなかった
僕の順番になりました
僕は教えています
私ていた
そう言うと先生
あなたの村2イボ誰かが負担するかもしれないの
そう言われたんですさらに修行後僕は呼び出されてい
あなたのその発言は宗教それ自体を否定して他の生徒の考えを否定する可能性があるん
だから次の授業でもう一度マジ質問をするね
そう言われたんです
でも正直
当時の僕を信仰している宗教がないというのおかしいと思わなかったから
かなり困惑しました
でもいい機会だなって思って自分の宗教観について考えてみました
ん
でも考えれば考えるほどっっ
自分のほとって全然知らないんだろう
自分がどんな人生を送ってきたん
どんな考え方をしていい
つまり自分の人生の物語は見えづらいん
そう気づいたんです
そんなときにふと自分のパソコンを開いてみると思う
180日間かさせたいてきたブログとっ
ニューヨーク先方の際に努めた自分の人生を振り返ったでものっ
ありましたね
それらを改めて眺めてみると
自分の人生という物語を再生しているような気分に入っ
自分を冠して見れたんです
その結果
僕の今までの人生で大切にしてきたのは人から見られて恥じない道を貫くこと
それは中学生の頃に読んだ1 b 謎の著書
武士道の考え方に近いんだと気づきましたその時自分を見せ見直すと僕を
それまでの目標に少し強くなれた気がしたけど
そして違う文化の相手であろうと
しっかりと自分の考えを持って接することができるようになりました
その時に自分が気づかなかった自分の物語が見えている
自分の知らない自分が見えた
つまり自分が持っている色の種類がベルような感覚がありました
ん
それはまさに
僕の世界が彩られていった初めての経験でした
この経験から僕をブログやメモのように毎日少しずつ自分と向き合うことで記述されて
い
自分だけの物語が自己認識を流し
世界を彩るということを知りました
でもこんなことを言っておいて僕自身をとっ
この軸を忘れて大切なものを失ってしまいました
これからお話しする二つ目のしてい
今日1日を振り返ったときに幸せだったと思える日々を過ごすかと思う
それに行くか関係してきます僕は高校卒業後
起業することを志して入学しました
大学では絶対学生起業したいと思って仲間とイベントチームを立ち上げている
大きなイベントを成功させてやると
なりふり構わず活動していました大学1年生の1月
この時期はイベントの案件を3つだけますし睡眠時間を削るような毎日
その時の僕は朝起きてから寝る瞬間まで
他の誰かが挙げた sns の投稿や世界のニュースなど
自分以外の誰かの情報に振り回されていました
そしてチームを結成する前に夢を語り合った仲間とは
いつしか仕事のことですれ違ってケンカばかり
僕の世界はどんどん色を失っていった
そんなある日
未知のウイルスが流行中というニュースが耳に入ってきました
ん
最初は気にしていなかったそのニュースも
日に日に状況が悪化して
イベントを開催していた僕たちにとっては見る身内に周りの可能性が潰されていくよう
なそんな感覚でした
僕もうまくいかないことにイライラしてまた仲間と喧嘩
そして気付くと g 6はバラバラになってチームは解散になっ
僕が一番大切にしたかったものを失った
そんな瞬間でした最初は大好きな仲間と成功したくて
チームを結成して頑張っていました
それぞれに目標があってそれを叶えるために頑張っていました
なのに気がついたら成長や努力という目に見えないものを意識すぎていっ
僕は目の前にあった目標も
仲間もっ
同時に失ってしまった
この時の僕は一つ目のステップである自己認識もできていなかった
更に言うと
日々を幸せだと思う憶えていなかった
それは
僕にとって何が大切で
何が幸せな状態なのか
それらを全く認識できていなかったからに他なりません
このことに気がついたの正直かなりあたりになってくれますね
それはイベントチームを解散してしばらく経った頃
日記を書き始めた時でした
当時の僕にとっても幸せはん
本当は仲間と一緒に挑戦することでした
何それを理解しないで毎日を過ごしていない
キビが全然者は知らなかっ
でも日記をつけ始めてからの日々はん
今自分が何に幸せを感じていた
今日1日が幸せだったのか
夜寝る前の5分間
そんなことを考えながら
需要になりました
その結果最近は幸せを感じながら
つまり物語を通して
自分にとって何が一番大切なのかを見つめ直すん
その上に日々の幸せがやってくるんだということを僕はこの経験から学びました
そして最後のステップ
これから先の未来の物語を思い描き
やりたいことに挑戦していくことについて干していきます
[音楽]
僕は今大学に通いながら
物語というサービスの開発をしています
僕自身もっと前に物語とぅにふぁいあー似合い
実践出来ていれば
もっと世界が色作家に見えたすこしー
大切な物も失わずに済んだのではない
そんな思いからもっとみんなが気軽にものがだけを残せるようになった
より多くの人の物語ます
世界を彩っている
こんなことを実現しちゃって今頑張っています
これが今も描いている
僕の未来の物語です
この鉄塔を聞いている皆さんには
マン u は希望違っても僕と同じように未来の目標を持っている方が多いのではない
でしょ
明るい未来を思い描いと日々をちっ
それは素晴らしいことだし
想像力を有しているわれわれ人間た記入された特権です
でもその目標が自己認識と日々の幸せの上にあるのでしょうなのか
1回今から僕と一緒に考えてみてほしい
ここまでお話ししてきたのは
過去と現在のの方についてです
昨日までも自分の物語を振り返ることで自分を見つめ直せます
そして今日1日の物語と向き合う
自分にとっての幸せが見えてきます
まずはこんなことをてる時でください
皆さんの目標は自己認識の上でかけられた目標でしょ
例えば
今日までのあなたの人生経験が生かせるようにしましょうですか
そして
過去の自分も同意できるような未来ですか
次にこんなことも聞いてみてください
その目標に向かって歩んでいる
あなたの今日という1日は幸せでした
そして
のにとって本当に大切な人や
あなた自身
幸せにできるような日々を送っていますか
これらのたいだけ
どれかにドキッとした方に僕から提案があります
今日から1日5分
5分だけ自分と向き合う時間を作ってみて下さい
そしてできればその向き合った結果を形に残してみてください
その形や媒体は自由です
日共助けるでもいいしまあ21枚
その日を象徴する写真を残すだけでもいい
とにかくその日を形に残して蓄積することで
のだけの物語となりいっ
未来のあなたを
伝えるものになっていきます
僕は何のために生きてるんだろう
僕は僕自身の物語を認識し
今日1日の物語が幸せれ
僕だけの物語をつくり出していく
そのために生きていきたい
このスピーチのたいってればいい
あなたの物語が世界を彩る
voodoo
自分の過去の物語を認識することで
あなたも知らないあなたの色が見えてきます
情報や仕事に追われる毎日の中でモノクロに見えていた世界も
あなた自身の幸せを考える時間を作れば
世界がいろ鮮やかに見えていくはずです
そしてより多くの人が自分だけの未来の物語を思い描くことができれば
それぞれの人が持つ個性という色が世界によう
増やしていきます
今の世界でを
余裕多くの人と早くより頻繁につながるようなことを目指す
技術やサービスがきび開発されています
インターネット sns は私のコミュニケーション方法や情報獲得方法を変革し世界
をより便利にすることを実現していました
そのような流れを全く否定する気はありません
[音楽]
これは6時実は僕たちの世界無限の可能性をもたらしてくれています
一方で便利になればなるほど自分という存在の優先順位が下がっていきます
全100年前の生活を想像してみてください
夜寝る前どんなことを考えながらいうふうについていたのでしょう
朝起きるときどんなことを最初に考えていたのでしょうかね
きっと今の僕たちよりも大切な人のことか
自分自身のことをもっと長く考えていたのではないかと思います
あなたの人生の主人公はあなた自身です
あなたの人生という物語を一番楽しめるのはあなた自身です
そしてあなただけの物語を作り出し
輝くものにしていけるのもあなたしかいません
もし今日の僕のステージ
そして物語というパイディアに共感してもらえたのならと
今日からあなただけな物語私にして残してみることから
ください